I'm um and dazzle
my name is Gerren you work out in
Houston Saturday the Superbowl got some
meetings cops broke up my meet up last
night everyone out of the street now go
that way it's crazy
thanks for the Houston police for
keeping me safe Jordan what do we what's
going on my shoulder what are we doing
so I'm working right now on building up
the overall strength and endurance of it
but beforehand you had a slight tear
feel like we're basically everything
we're doing is to work around the slight
tear while building up the strength and
endurance rare situation where the left
is stronger than the right
somebody just DM me about the Joe Rogan
podcast and he said you know
great observation great guy very nice
note said you know in yang you know
you've got the yang that you're
competitive but that thing that Joe is
talking about with your daughter and the
basketball in this was maybe you need to
look at the yen you got a look at both
sides I don't think people understand I
think I look at the ilyinka both sides
quite a bit I live both sides quite a
bit I'm pulling for both sides quite a
bit but here's the difference when I'm
on the field I'm all in one way
like everybody wants a micro yin and
yang but that's not how it works
it's a macro yin-yang on the big picture
super balanced but when I'm on [ __ ]
the field competing you have to go 100
Jordan how do I work out 1% every time
that's it and I [ __ ] hate working out
but that's the part you can't be 5050
working out 50/50 in relationships 50/50
in in your escapism 50/50 in the way you
play that's why everybody's average you
have to be macro yin and yang micro all
in one way or the other right here's
good man thanks yeah
got it 11:30 at night heading to another
meeting right now early days of Boehner
sports Superbowl some some ups some
downs you know real life stuff but I
love it I wish we were filming
vaynermedia early on because we had
plenty of ups and downs those first two
years people think it comes overnight
but it just doesn't running my ass off
here it's Superbowl not even stay for
the game leaving at 7:00 a.m. to get
home but I need to watch Pats
and except I'm just really enjoying it I
enjoy the grind I love the process I
love that you guys get to see something
from the beginning when it was nothing
it was a little seed and you get to see
the tough days we've got some coming and
the great thing is so enjoying it the
day with AJ grinding
love the journey my friends I could say
anything to love the journey because if
you don't love the journey you'll never
get through the first quarter
[Music]
- 18 in the morning hustled made some
stuff happen feel productive feeling
good
got it just work you know how'd you get
it I worked
[Music]